c'est une vidéo qui montre le nombre de
débris spatiaux autour de la Terre au
fil des années il y en aurait
actuellement près de 160 millions selon
les nationsunis alors c'est des débris
de quelques centimètres parfois pour
qu'on comprenne bien c'est quoi
exactement ces débris et pourquoi c'est
un problème potentiel l'essentiel de des
débris vraiment qui existent aujourd'hui
en orbite c'est le résultat de test
antiatellite en fait c'est des pays qui
ont voulu prouver qu'ils avaient la
technologie pour détruire un satellite
pour que tout le monde comprenne
mondialement qu' savent faire ça en
général ils détruisent un des leur mais
ça ça crée et ben un nuage de de de
boulon tu vois tout ce que tu peux
imaginer de petites pièces de petits
débris et c'est essentiellement ça que
qui a participer à la à la prolifération
des débris eu après soit dit en passant
cette cette vidéo elle est bien mais
mais l'échelle des débris par rapport à
l'échelle de la planète est très grande
tu vois si tu regardes par rapport à la
planète un petit point blanc c'est la
taille d'un département en vrai c'est
une pièce de 2 € tu vois donc il y a
quand même de la place pour passer c'est
pas la la ceinture d'astéroïde dans
C'est pas évité comme dans les films